let's see if we can write 0.15 as a
fraction so the important thing here is
to look at where what place these digits
are in so this one right over here this
is in the tenths place so it's you could
view that as 1 times 1/10 this 5 right
over here is in the hundredths place so
you could view that as 5 times 1 over
100 so if I were to rewrite this I can
rewrite this as a sum of this one
represents 1 times 1/10 so that little
be 1/10 plus and this five represents
five times one hundredths so it would be
plus five hundredths plus five
hundredths and if we want to add them up
we want to find a common denominator the
common denominator is 100 both 10 and
they're the least common multiple of
both 100 multiple of both 10 and 100 so
we can rewrite this as something over
100 plus something over 100 plus
something over 100 this isn't going to
change this was already 5 over 100 if we
multiplied the denominator here by 10
that's what we did we multiplied it by
10 then we have to multiply this
numerator by 10 and so this is the same
thing as 10 over 100 and now we're ready
to add this is the same thing as 10 plus
5 is 15 over 100 and you could have done
that a little bit quicker just by
inspecting this you would say look my
smallest place right over here is in the
hundreds place instead of calling this
1/10 I could call this literally 10
hundredths or I could say this whole
thing is 1500s 1500s and now if I want
to reduce this to lowest terms we can
let's see both the numerator and the
denominator is divisible by 5 so let's
divide them both by 5 and so the
numerator 15 divided by 5 is 3 the
denominator 100 divided by 5 is 20 and
that's about as simplified as we can get